[Music]
and you mind if I join you
hey fat dude I'm sorry you uh not Yeo's
me have you kind of beat it cuz you're a
distraction what brings you down here go
on vacation here with your boyfriend uh
no I'm just here with them my mom make
ie me body coming near me so why are you
dressed like powder this song is very
dangerous
mom it feels like you're putting it on
just here when you needed here let's go
out today here are makeup boobs we're
going out Emily I am NOT going out at
night everything shouldn't be so scary
oh wait damn we'll shoot one in four
tourists are kidnapped not true one two
three somebody's missing I'm a man well
drinking with a man in a foreign country
smart responsible thing to do we need an
amazing adventure where the hell are we
the scenic route
what's open number
Karen he says I already them before you
told me one two three work Oh change it
I will get us out of here I need to
believe in me telling maybe that guy's
okay
I saw his brains why can't you just make
me don't ever listen I need your help
mom and I got kidnapped State Department
my mom and sister they've been taken I
imagine you have commando squad for
underground criminals who were tried for
a crime they didn't commit
sounds like d88 is the a-team is do you
have an eight-team why did I ever let
you talk me into this you should just
listen to you I love you this is great
we've all gotta get out of here you know
we're okay yeah we've
you messed with the wrong [ __ ] yeah
go I'm gonna count down I'm gonna do it
Chris please 199 adventure Emily I can't
go to South America wait what my band is
really blowing up right now and where
I'm going there's gonna be like a ton of
immigration